NARRATOR: On Alaska's wild
the hunt is on.
We're going to head over here
and see if we can find a fox.
NARRATOR: Bear
tracker, Mike Horstman
makes his living guiding
outlanders who come to hunt
the island's giant predators.
My guiding and the hunts
that I do here basically
makes up my yearly income,
subsidized by some fishing,
trapping.
NARRATOR: The
40-year veteran knows
the secrets of this island.
And today, he and
his hunting dog Adele
are chasing down a rare quarry.
The foxes are bigger
here because they
just have so much food.
There's red fox, cross
fox, but the silver fox
is what brings the most money.
Get over here.
[rabbit call]
I'm using a call that
imitates a rabbit
that a fox, a hawk, an eagle--
that something is killing--
and it's a distress call.
[rabbit call]
NARRATOR: But
seven-year-old Adele
is Mike's true secret weapon.
You see anything
out there, honey?
NARRATOR: He's
trained her from a pup
to retrieve kills on a hunt.
Sometimes you can sit
here and call all day,
and it wouldn't
make any difference.
There's none within
earshot of here.
Let's go down-- We're just going
to sneak along through here
and just be quiet,
pay attention,
and see what we've can up with.
There's a fox track right there.
Is that a fresh one?
Yeah, there's fox
tracks all over.
See if there's any fox out
here in these fields mousing.
[rabbit call]
There's one right there.
[gunshot]
Get him!
Nah, I don't know.
Nah, I don't see any blood.
NARRATOR: Mike narrowly misses
his shot at a Kodiak cross fox.
There's no blood, there's
no hair, there's no fox.
NARRATOR: But a rare fur
comes with a promise of a $200
pay day, so he's not
ready to quit yet.
So we'll set it up again.
See if we can find another one.
Hopefully, we'll have a little
more luck closer to the river.
NARRATOR: And with
nearly 40 years
of surviving on this
island under his belt,
he knows where to look.
Get down here, honey.
Get down.
[rabbit call]
There he is, right there.
[gunshot]
Go ahead!
Get him!
NARRATOR: Mike Horstman has
a silver fox in his sights.
Go ahead!
I got him!
NARRATOR: And his hunting
partner, seven-year-old Adele,
races in to seal the deal.
Nice job!
Adele, as long as she's been
with me-- like seven years
now-- she's caught lots of fox.
If that fox is wounded,
she's going to grab him,
dispatch him, and it's over.
You got him?
Good girl!
That's good.
That's a beauty.
Beauty, yeah.
This is the one everybody wants.
So, now we'll take
this one, and we're
going to go back towards
camp and skin it accordingly.